spewing lava turned the night sky red
the eruption happened in the early hours
of the morning a column of ash shot
three kilometers into the sky for those
looking on it was a thrilling and
nerve-wracking spectacle honestly we
were scared there was a lot of fire
spewing out it was going up really high
because it was a very strong explosion
we thought it was seismic we felt the
explosion blossom villa rica is situated
near the city of pucon home to around
22,000 people it's also a popular
holiday destination thousands of
residents and tourists were forced to
leave the area beneath the volcano
before traveling to the region President
Michelle Bachelet shirred Chileans that
authorities were taking all necessary
precautions several measures have been
taken and at guaranteeing the safety of
the population at our last count we have
evacuated nearly 4,000 people by the
time the Sun rose villa rica was again
quiet but there were still signs of the
powerful eruption the molten rock caused
snow to melt and rivers to rise it's not
clear when people will be able to return
to their homes they simply don't know
when the next eruption will be